our next question for the president
comes from Clearwater Florida here it is
thank you for taking our question mr.
president I'm Mary rose and I'm mark and
we own Rose mark grips were small
business in Florida that makes golf
putter grips we do not qualify for the
payroll protection program because we do
all the work ourselves we don't have any
payroll employees we're wondering if
there's something in the works that will
help us out as we have numerous bills
that still need to be paid and do not
qualify for current programs that are
out there well first of all I love you
business and both I can speak for Brett
we could both use a nice putter grip and
business but I don't know about you
Brett I haven't played golf with a
long-planned much we haven't played too
much lately but I will say this what we
have to do is get get it open
I see New Jersey's opening up their golf
courses a Florida is now opening up
their golf courses parks are opening
beaches are opening at some point we
have to open our country and people are
going to be safe we've learned a lot
we've learned about the tremendous
contagion but we have no choice we have
to we can't stay close as a country
we're not going to have a country left
but Morgan Melrose are saying they fell
through the cracks we got a lot of
questions that the bank didn't give it
to him or they didn't qualify and is
that what do you how I understand and
and all we can do in that case is we
have to bring back we have to bring back
the business now all of that's opening
and they're you know their businesses
Golf which is a nice business and we're
opening up that whole golf sector the
sports sector where I wish I could help
them I'd even help them personally
because you know what it's not a big
business but for them it's a big it's a
big thing and they probably do a
fantastic job I can see they've such
great spirit what we do is we loan the
money to small businesses but not
necessarily business you know it's an
unusual circumstance where they're each
their own employee I think what I'm
going to do is I'm going to take a look
at that maybe there is something we can
do because all the stimulus in the world
really can't solve the problem of demand
in a country right radius how do you
stimulate the my greatest thing we could
do is get rid of the virus because then
everything comes back together than ever
you don't need stimulus once that's
happening and what is happening is the
sympathy stim you know we're talking
about three trillion not just two
trillion three
it could even go to six and we're gonna
have a tremendous year next year because
of what we're doing and laying the seeds
you know we're talking 30 million jobs
that we've saved 30 million jobs that's
unheard of in addition we saved the
airlines
we saved others you know one thing
happened on Friday that was very big
Boeing a great company then they had the
problem that people know a different
problem and then they end up with this
where their sales are cut so badly
because of this which is by the way also
happening in Europe as you know with
their competitor no airplanes they
floated a bond issue borrowed money very
very successfully at a good rate on
Friday that's a big step the markets are
there the markets are open I believe it
was 30 billion dollars so the markets
are there that's a big step we didn't
have to do anything with Boeing they
went out to the markets and they were
able to borrow a lot of money and it's
going to be a great company again but
we've done that with the airlines the
airlines Brett we're having the best
year they've ever had ever in the
history and then we had to we had to
turn off the airline's way to turn off
everything and we did the right thing
but we never want to have to do it again
let's go to Carolyn Perkins she's a
retired nurse and an elementary school
guidance counselor and here's her
comment question
president Trump my husband and I thank
you your family and your staff for your
great dedication to our country we pray
for you every day the question I have is
about your manner of presentation why do
you use descriptive words that could be
classified as bullying and why do not
directly answer the questions asked by
the press but instead speak of past
successes and generally ramble the u.s.
I need you please let go of those
behaviors that are turning people away
from you please hold on to your
wonderful attributes that make you our
great leader and let go of other
characteristics that do not serve you
good I think I like that question I'm
not sure but I think I like that
question I appreciate it I appreciate
the prayers too very much look I am
greeted with a hostile press the likes
of which no president has ever seen the
closest would be that gentleman right up
there they always said Lincoln nobody
got treated worse than Lincoln I believe
I am treated worse you're there you see
those press conferences they come at me
with questions that are disgraceful to
be honest disgraceful their manner of
presentation and their words and I feel
that if I was kind to them I'd be I'd be
walked off the stage I mean if they come
at you with the most horrible horrendous
biased questions and you see it 94 and
95 percent of the press is hostile and
yet if you look in Florida today we had
hundreds and hundreds of boats going up
and down the intercoastal Trump Trump we
have tremendous support but the media is
they might as well be in the Democrat
Party and why I don't know we fixed our
military we fixed the vet you know if
you look at the the VA you take a look
at what's going on with our vets they
have choice now and we have
accountability we're able to get rid of
people that don't treat our vets well
they've been trying to do that for 44
years and because of civil service and
the unions you couldn't do it the
biggest thing is choice we've we've done
such choice where if a vet can't see a
doctor quickly they go outside they get
a doctor they get fixed up we pay the
bill instead of waiting for five weeks
seven weeks look at how well these
things are running we rebuilt our
military we've done we had the greatest
tax cut biggest tax cut in history all
of the things we've done and yet we have
a very hostile press and you understand
maybe you're not gonna say it or admit
it and maybe you shouldn't but nobody
has ever seen anything like this so I
really appreciate the question and I
very much appreciate the sentiment
behind the question but I'm standing up
there and instead of asking me a normal
question the level of anger and hatred
I'll look at him I'll say what's your
problem what is your problem you know I
believe we've done more than any
president in the history of our country
in the first three years three and a
half years I really believe that when
you look even if you look space force
space force also take a look at
terrorism al Baghdady
we killed him Salameh knee we killed him
we killed the worst terrorists in the
world we got rid of Isis for you know we
took over a hundred percent of the
Caliphate when I took it over the
Caliphate was all over the place Obama
the elect
we'll come down to a referendum on how
you handle this growth it'll be bigger
than that no I think the elections going
to come down too I hope it does because
we've done a great job
we had no ventilators we had no testing
we had nothing I had I inherited empty
empty no ammunition our military was bad
we've rebuilt our military 1.5 trillion
dollars we have the best military by far
in the world it's rebuilt it's either
all new or the equipment's coming in
which is great but you know what also
medically we had empty cupboards with
the cupboards I say the cupboards were
empty we have an incredible testing we
have the best testing system right now
in the world we also make all the
ventilators I spent the weekend at Camp
David speaking to and a prior couple of
days speaking to heads of other
countries that are desperate from for
ventilators and we now have so many
ventilators you know a month ago that's
all they were talking about was
ventilators the team of people that did
this job was incredibly the biggest
mobilization since World War two mr.
president the governor's credit you for
the ventilators across the board
you mentioned the Democrats and leaving
the cupboards bare from the previous
administration you're not surprised to
hear that the former Vice President Joe
Biden pushes back against that he
tweeted just the other day we left a
playbook he ignored it we created an
office to prepare for pandemics he
gutted it
we had CDC officials in China to detect
and contain the outbreaks he pulled them
out Trump can try and shift blame all he
wants but the fact is his actions left
us unprepared
first of all Jill Biden didn't write
that that was written from a young man
that got very good grades at a very good
school that was not written by him I
promise you that Joe Biden just so you
know when I closed our borders to China
I did the China ban I didn't want to do
that I did something that nobody wanted
to do Joe Biden said he's in a phobic
he's a racist they call me a racist and
I saved hundreds of thousands of lives
and he actually apologized with a letter
on a Friday night saying he made the
right move it wasn't well played by the
press but he said I made the right move
no if we would have listened to Jill
Biden look how badly they did
swine flu the h1n1 which he calls the
opposite h1 it's h1n1 swine flu
look how badly they did on that look how
badly they've done in so many other
things I mean the place our military was
a mess or just about everything was a
mess look at what they did in the Middle
East what's gone on in the Middle East
and in all fairness in the Middle East I
look at the previous administration for
getting us in because that was the
single worst decision made in this
country's history the single worst
getting into the Middle East just so you
understand
we've spent eight trillion dollars in
the Middle East what do we have for it
what do we have for it and things are
moving very nicely in the other
direction our next question for the
president comes from Rob in Ohio hello
I'm Rob from Columbus Ohio the
coronavirus is disproportionately
affecting communities of color I wanted
to know what your administration will do
to address this so we are working on
that very hard and you're right a
hundred percent that if you look at
African American by the way Asian
American also in Hispanic American they
are very much more affected people are
not a hundred percent sure it could be
because it's a certain segment that does
work together restaurants and different
jobs which are affected a lot but we're
coming out with a report in two weeks on
it and I want to get to the bottom of it
too because it's a totally
disproportionate effect it really is
it's pretty amazing actually next
questions from Tripp great greeby he's a
freshman at the University of
wisconsin-madison and here's this
question for you mr. president if you're
elected to a second term what's your
plan to be more fiscally responsible to
either reduce or eliminate the deficit
in response to increased federal
spending for the coronavirus stimulus
packages so we have billions of dollars
coming in right now from other countries
we have money coming in people are
paying now for military protection
people are paying for other things as
you know I'm putting taxes on other
countries where they've taken advantage
of us especially by the way China China
never gave ten cents to our country he
they ripped off our country for many men
tell this the president she directly in
a nice manner and in a not-so-nice
manner I get along with him should have
done something different on this but we
made an incredible trade deal we have
tens of billions of dollars pouring in
President Obama and Joe Biden didn't do
anything
China just had a field day with our
country and then you look at his sudden
walking out with a billion and a half
dollars give me a break on that and I
can go back to President Bush and I can
go back before President Bush to China
ripped this country off for many many
decades and I stopped it then of course
you had this Horror Show coming in the
the plague it came in so now it's a
different story but we've taken in
billions and what have I done with it
I've given some of the money's because
they were targeted by China to the
farmers and to the ranchers twelve
billion dollars
two years ago sixteen billion dollars
last year and we have a lot this year
and we by the way have many times those
numbers left over from all the money
we're making from China that never
happened before you have 25 trillion in
debt as of today and there's more on the
burner that's possibly coming down the
pipe
what's the number we're gonna cut back
very substantially plus we're gonna have
great growth this country is going to
grow like crazy as soon as we get it
going and we're going to start making
our products here hey Brett you've known
me for a long time I've been talking
about this for a long time it's one of
the reasons I would say border security
the military and trade these are the
three primary reasons I got elected this
is a very big thing for me I made a deal
Japan is now paying us 40 billion
dollars they weren't paying us they
weren't doing anything they were selling
us they were selling us cars we wouldn't
do anything to tax them but we couldn't
sell cars in Japan Japan we did a deal
for 40 billion dollars a year look at
South Korea we did the deal in South
Korea Mexico Canada u.s. MCA the NATO
the the NAFTA deal was so horrible it
was so horrible but I said a word just
now NATO my biggest fan in the whole
world is the Secretary General of NATO
Stoltenberg great man great gentleman he
said nobody has ever done for NATO what
I've done we got a hun
and fifty billion dollars the money that
they're paying other countries they
weren't paying we were paying for a
hundred percent of NATO and now other
countries are putting up I went to him I
said listen you can either pay oh we're
not gonna be why would we be protecting
all of these countries 28 countries
total why would we be protecting you're
not even paying your bills you're
delinquent
Martha they're putting up a hundred and
fifty billion dollars a year and it's
going up to four hundred billion and no
other president has ever done anything
like that we have to take a break but I
just want to ask you quickly there's a
lot of people who say why you talk about
making it here in America why are all of
the antibiotics made in China can you
give me a date by which we will be
self-sufficient in antibiotics in this
country and what kind of incentive would
you give manufacturers of
pharmaceuticals to make sure that we are
not dependent on China anymore for this
so the reason it took place is because
other people that sat in this chair
maybe not right here but this is a
beautiful place because they were
foolish you could even say because they
were stupid because they allowed this to
happen and it's not only China you take
a look at Ireland they make our drugs
they everybody makes our drugs except us
and we've already done it we're coming
out with things numbers you're seeing
numbers of innovations that we've made
in the past and things are being
announced already but we're bringing
that whole supply chain back nobody has
to tell me to do it I've been talking
about that for years now the one that
you see you don't see it you see it with
cars you see it with other things people
never looked at medicine but it's always
been about medicine because we have at
least 94 95 % of our medicines are made
in order to do the vaccine well it's an
incredible thing they're American
companies well I'd like to be able to do
over here I don't want to do it in China
that I can tell you but I think we're
gonna do it here and if we do it
someplace else look we have to get a
vaccine whoever gets it I'm gonna I'm
gonna be their best fan and I want it I
need the vaccine we need this country
needs the vaccine and you're gonna have
it by the end of the year I firmly
believe that 94% of antibiotics made in
this country do you have a target date
for that I think we will have it done
within two years you know it doesn't go
that quickly
and frankly you put me in a very bad
negotiating position by asking me those
questions you know we're talking about
this now I'm supposed to call up my guys
I mean you put me in a very bad
negotiating position and I'm not blaming
you that's you that's your job
but you know you're taking my cards away
cuz I don't want to be talking this way
I've done a lot but it gets exposed when
you answer I assume the show is a big
show right it's going to do very well
tonight but you do take away a lot of my
cards when you're answering and it's
give me a question like that you
understand that yes here's the bottom
line I met with the drug company six
months ago I said you're gonna start
making the drugs here you're gonna start
making them here and they do it for two
reasons a cost reason but it's no longer
so much cost because we can do things
here for the same price and in some
cases less and then you don't have the
transportation problems we're taking
care of our look another reason I got
elected and some people don't like the
sound of it and other countries don't
like it but I said I'm sorry it's called
America first and we're all about
America first that's what we're about
let's get back to our questions
gentlemen thank you for being here mr.
secretary bet that's good to see you
wait what a beautiful shot as night
falls over the Lincoln Memorial here in
Washington DC welcome to all of you
great to have you here let's go to our
next questioner Kylie Patterson from
Baltimore she is the director of
economic inclusion at Johns Hopkins
University President Trump in the face
of the Kovach 19 pandemic millions of
Americans have lost their jobs how you
respond to the joblessness while also
ensuring that our infrastructure is
better than ever
have you considered investing in the
infrastructure in our highways our
railways our airports and bridges as a
way to create jobs for America mr.
president it's to you but you can
obviously follow me here if you'd like
to love to have both speak about it but
infrastructure is very important it's
also important to the Democrats by the
way that's something we actually do get
along I want to see a payroll tax cut on
both sides a very strong one because
that's going to really put people to
work
but infrastructure is so important to
our country our roads our excuse me
they're going to hell we can't get
infrastructure approve
now we have a time we have a period of
time when we can get infrastructure done
by both parties and we're looking at
that in addition as you know they want
bailouts for the states the Democrats
and really it's a number of states that
frankly have not been managed well by
Democrats over a long period of time so
we have to be very careful about that
very careful but we will be doing
infrastructure and I told Steve just
today we're not doing anything unless we
get a payroll tax cut that is so
important to the success of our country
and to the following year because I
think that the following year has a
chance to be one of our best years that
we can all believe that that is how you
stimulate demand is that payroll tax cut
I mean where do you look at that in the
big picture well the president's been
very clear on that and he's spoken about
a payroll tax cut over the years but I
would also say into that viewer that
that the the immediate way we deal with
joblessness is by opening up America
again the guidelines that the president
produced that now we see some 41 states
produced plans for a phased responsible
reopening of our economy it's going to
create jobs in the immediate and I just
think where we are today despite the
heartbreaking losses of of more than
67,000 Americans where we are today is
is still a tribute to our health care
workers to the sacrifices and American
families and businesses have made over
the last few months and if we continue
to practice that social distancing those
mitigation efforts as we go through a
phase reopening will create jobs today
and with the president's vision for
infrastructure a payroll tax cut I have
no doubt that the second half of this
year we're gonna see an American
comeback and next year I agree with the
president I think we're to have one of
the best years in the history of our
economy mr. secretary we had questions
earlier about people feeling like they
fell through the cracks wondering you
know how they're going to factor in if
they didn't get the PPP loan what are
you looking at for the next thing well
let me just first comment before we say
the next thing let me just emphasize
what we've done and the president was
very clear keeping Americans at work
putting them back to work protecting
American business was our number one
priority an unprecedented way we now
have three trillion dollars that we're
putting into the economy that's just
beginning so for those Americans who
haven't received their money yet they
will over the next few weeks last week
alone we did 2.1 million of small
business loans averaging eighty five
thousand dollars or less already sent an
enormous number over a hundred and
twenty million direct deposits and
checks the President created enhanced
unemployment so the president has been
very clear in an unprecedented way for
us to support the economy and in the
next round we will go back and work with
Congress just as we have before to make
sure we protect American business
American workers and to stimulate the
economy going forward so let's go to our
next question for you are all from
filter coffees the president of tol
cough food products which is family
company been in the business for over 90
years they've four locations South
Carolina Georgia Oregon and Tennessee
and here is Phil's question for my firm
the current tariffs add up to almost
$60,000 in monthly additional costs for
my operations lifting these tariffs
would help us speed the recovery for
many of us by allowing those funds to be
used to hire workers invest in equipment
and recoup some of the cash we've spent
to weather the current economic
situation would you consider permanently
or even temporarily reducing or
eliminating those types so Phil we're
looking at different things but you have
to remember I've taken those tariffs and
given a lot of them to the farmers and
farmers that would have been really
forced out of business by China when
they were targeted because China never
had a target us because China was
ripping our country off we were losing
500 billion dollars a year to China four
years and three hundred million two
hundred billion five hundred and forty
four billion five hundred and forty four
billion a few years ago and and what I'm
doing is and what I've done is taken a
lot of money out of China and I've given
it back to Phil and other people because
I've given it back to the not all of it
because we've had we had so much so much
money came in from China but we gave as
I said 12 billion to
years ago 16 billion and this year we
have 19 billion that were distributing
to the farmers nobody's ever done that
no presidents ever done that but Phil is
obviously bringing in supplies from
China that he's getting he's paying
tariffs on would you encourage him to
try to find other countries to buy those
things but you know what they were also
getting they're getting big payments the
farmers are getting big payments and by
the way they are the most incredible
people they don't even want the payments
you know they say to me some something
that almost no other group but I can say
practically no other group they want a
level playing field we had a meeting
with them with Mike and they came in and
I said we're gonna give you this they
said sir honestly we don't want anything
we just want a level playing field
because for 18 years really it's longer
than that they've been taken advantage
of not only by China by everybody
including Canada including many many
countries that you wouldn't even think
so the farmers now with the new US MCA
and all of the other things and as far
as Phil I understand it but we're giving
billions and billions of that money to
the farmers and have a lot of money that
goes back into the Treasury and Steve is
the proud recipient from the standpoint
of the Treasury but are you considering
new tariffs on China as sort of a
punishment for their handling of the
virus well it's the ultimate punishment
I will tell you that I don't have
experts like Mike again I don't like to
tell you what I'm because you know we're
all playing a very complicated game of
chess or poker name whatever you want a
name but it's not checkers that I can
tell you we have a very complicated game
going our country was being ripped off
by every nation in the world and now we
have made unbelievable strides
unfortunately then we get hit by this
whole situation but we have done so well
we have taken in so much money going
before the virus China had the worst
year they had in 67 years that's the
reason and I'm not happy about that but
what it does is it says they were taking
us for a ride right but today that
America has ever done any at any time
he's saying Americans feel it experts
said just your mention of that helped
drive the markets down Thursday and
Friday but but I'm just wondering if you
were really seriously think about
tariffs at a minimum are the greatest
negotiating
that we have ever devised that we're
never used for negotiation president she
only made the deal with us this gonna
buy 250 billion now we're gonna have to
see what's going on because of what
happened this was done you know months
before the the virus but we're getting
you know by two hundred and fifty
billion dollars worth of our product two
hundred and fifty billion then in by two
said they didn't want to buy from us
they took advantage of our country now
they have to buy and if they don't buy
will terminate the deal very simple but
by using the tariffs that's the only
reason the one thing that he said we
must get rid of tariffs I said we're not
going to get rid of tariffs you got to
treat our country with respect you've
been ripping off our country for many
years the World Trade Organization has
ripped off this country that's when
China became an economic power and by
the way you have world trading you have
world health the World Health
Organization has been a disaster
everything they said was wrong and their
China centric all they do is they they
agree with China whatever general wants
to do so our country perhaps foolishly
in retrospect has been paying 450
million dollars a year to the World
Health Organization and China has been
paying 38 million dollars a year but
they were more political than all of our
leaders previous so we'll see what I do
with that I'm gonna have to make a
decision on that but we're not happy
because what they did what world health
did they missed every single call
there's a question today with it yeah
let's let's go to Moyes can we pull up
Moyes right now he's from Crawford I
think yep mr. president I have a
question for you is there enough
evidence that China misled global
community or by the scorn of ours if
it's so harsh a global community respond
well I don't think there's any question
about it we wanted to go in they didn't
want us to go in early very early you'll
see that because things are coming out
that are pretty compelling now so I
don't think there's any question don't
forget China tried to blame it first on
some of our soldiers that turned out to
not go too far and I really got very
upset with that that was not
right and then they tried to blame it in
Europe is it how did Europe get involved
all of a sudden you know Italy suffered
probably more than anybody per capita
but Italy Spain France now is on an
additional lockdown they've got
tremendous problems all of Europe it's
been a disaster and you know when I put
a ban on those people went for the most
part not here and I'm not happy about
this it's terrible because its life
whether it's here in Europe but we put a
ban on very early on China coming in
they went to Europe most of those people
went to Europe
that's why Italy was so badly affected
and you just see what they're going
through China tried to blame Europe for
this no I know you saw evidence that
gave you a high confidence that the
virus came from the Wuhan lab not that
it was created there perhaps but that it
came from there at the right time we get
illuminate any more about that yeah
we're gonna be given a very strong
report as to exactly what we think
happened and I think it'll be very
conclusive is there any suggestion that
it was anything nefarious or that it was
just a mistake so I think they made
personally I think they made a horrible
mistake and they didn't want to admit it
we wanted to go in they didn't want us
there even world health wanted to go in
they were admitted but much later you
know not immediately and my opinion is
they made a mistake they tried to cover
it they tried to put it out it's like a
fire you know it's really like trying to
put out a fire they couldn't put out the
fire what they really treated the world
badly on they stopped people going into
China but they didn't stop people going
into the USA and all over the world so
you could fly out of Wuhan where the
primary problem was all of the problem
essentially also where the lab is
but you could fly out of Wuhan and you
could go to different parts of the world
but you couldn't go to Beijing and you
couldn't go to any place in China so
what's that all about in other words
they knew they had a problem I think
they were embarrassed by the problem
very embarrassed and you know the case
could be made they said hey look this is
gonna have a huge impact on China and we
might as well let the rest of the world
because the last people they want we've
had a great year against China prior to
the virus coming I told you 67 or so
years
the worst economy they've had worse
they've almost on record that they've
ever had because of my negotiations and
because they tax them on the product
that they brought in and by the way they
paid for that tax it wasn't our people
they paid for that tax they devalued
their currency but here's the thing
they allowed this to go into our country
they allowed it to go into other
countries although change how you feel
about president G does it change your
relationship with him look I finished a
trade deal that everybody said would be
impossible to get and not only a trade
there was a great deal for this country
but that was done months before the
virus came I'm not going to say anything
I had a very good relationship he's a
strong man he's a tough man but I have a
very good relationship with him but this
should never have happened
this should never have happened this
virus should not have spread all over
the world they should have put it out
they should have let us and other people
in other countries go in and put it out
because people knew what was happening
we have another question about the
situation getting people back to work in
the US air travel 95 percent down from a
year ago according the TSA our next
question coming from an aircraft
technician in Texas hi I'm Joe from
Owenton Texas I work for a major airline
how can we ensure the health safety of
our passengers and mr. president what
advice would you give future presidents
to prevent this from happening to our
country again I love that second
question I just love it but you probably
your airline was probably saved by us
because Steve and all of the people we
have we you know chose the smartest
people on Wall Street to help us who
else is better than these people that's
what they do and by the way they're
working for a very tiny fee because I
said I don't want to pay him a lot of
money for doing this we're giving them
money to save the airlines I'm not
looking to make them rich they're rich
enough so I said we're gonna get the
best people pay him some costs but pay
him very little I hope you kept doing
that Steve right did mr. price hope I'm
gonna check you anyway but we we have
this morning people we saved the
airlines
we saved the airlines with 50 25 and 25
billion dollars so it's 50 billion
dollars which is a very small price to
pay that we're having the best the best
year ever
as far as your question of the future we
have to bring our product back home we
have to make our product in this country
we can't be hostage because that's what
we are we can't be hostage to other
countries China in particular but also
to other countries we can't ever let
that happen again
mr. vice president there is that balance
you know people are afraid to get on a
plane if they can eventually and
balancing that fear of getting people
back to work or dealing with that fear
well the president brought the airlines
in very early on and we want to commend
all of our great airlines for continuing
to operate - where people needed to do
essential travel but to your point Bret
ninety five percent reduction in the
number of passengers and it's one of the
reasons why we're providing financial
assistance to those airlines and I just
say to that hardworking American that
we're going to bring it back and the
best thing we can do for airlines the
best thing we can do for all of American
businesses is as the president often
says is put the coronavirus in the past
and the good news is that we're doing
that we we're watching the trends
literally every day county-by-county all
across the country
in the hot spots for seeing
stabilization and declines
hospitalizations are going down we've
even seen over the last five days the
death rate has gone down and again one
life lost is too many I just had a
friend who lost her mom in Kentucky and
she grieved that she couldn't be there
to hold her hand when she went home to
be with the Lord but the fact that we
are seeing declines again it's a tribute
to the American people and on the
president's behalf on our whole team's
behalf I just want to urge the American
people as we continue to take important
steps toward reopening our economy
getting people able to travel and enjoy
the great benefits of this country and
do business around America we're gonna
do it in the way the president described
in that phased approach where we take
careful measures to do it in a safe and
responsible way but I'm absolutely
convinced that that by early summer we
could we could have this economy
to move again and with all the
tremendous advances were making in
medicine and what we've learned in this
healthcare will we'll get this economy
roaring and bring America all the way
back I want to get to the next viewer
but I also want to ask you secretary a
quick question the some of these states
that have a you know unfunded pension
debt right we're throwing trillions of
dollars at this effort to renew the
country renew the economy should they
get money if they have not taken good
care of their finances before this
happened we're not looking to bail out
states that were poorly managed what we
did do in the Kerr's Act there was a
hundred and fifty billion dollars that
was allocated to the States for
coronavirus expenses one of the things
the president just instructed me to do
and we sent out guidance on Friday that
states can use the money for policemen
firemen first responders without limits
so we can make sure that none of those
people who have been fighting the
frontlines in any way are impacted by
the states having lower revenues but the
president's very clear we're looking to
help States but we're not bailing out
states finances Carly alderman from
Merritt Island Florida wants to know
this take a listen
hi mr. president my husband and I both
work at our local church and I think a
lot of us churchgoers are just wondering
when we might be able to get back to an
in-person church service do you have any
idea when this might be I hope it's
going to be very soon because I'm seeing
things that I don't like seeing I see
some churches they are literally staying
in their car with the window closed I
guess it comes out through the radio the
the service and they were getting
arrested and they're sitting in a car
and the cars are even far away and they
say close your windows so it has to come
in electronically and I'm saying why
can't they do that or they'll go in a
field some field and they'll be they'll
have a good minister pastor it could be
a rabbi could be a person of faith and
what happens is in some places not in
all places I would say in most places
they really sympathize but I do and I've
been listening to services over the last
four or five weeks some very very good
people and everybody knows who I've been
listening to and we go different person
last week it was a cardinal Dolan at st.
Patrick's Cathedral which a place I'm
very familiar with but we've had pastors
and ministers I will say this it's
wonderful to watch people over a laptop
but it's not like being at a church and
we have to get our people back to
churches and we're going to start doing
it soon the Attorney General sent a memo
directing US Attorney's to be on the
lookout for health restrictions that
could interfere with constitutional
rights there are a lot of people who
cheered that because you know they do
want to go back to church and as you're
talking about but there are others who
fear he might be encouraging people to
do things that might be unsafe at the
time when some states are going up yeah
no he's not doing well there's not too
many states that I know of that are
going up almost everybody is headed in
the right direction I was with a man who
got hit very very hard in many ways over
the last little while Phil Murphy from
New Jersey people don't realize that's
the single most dense state and who
would think that but New Jersey is very
dense the Manhattan overflow the New
York overflow and those numbers are now
even coming because of very I mean not
his fault he's doing a really good job
as governor I'll say he's a Democrat and
I'll say it and he's been through a lot
even himself physically you know he just
went through a very big problem there's
people know he I think he's done a
really good job and even those numbers
are coming down New Jersey was really
hit hard no I think most of the numbers
are coming down we're on the right side
of it but we want to keep it that way
but we also want to get back to work the
people want to get back to work you know
I've seen it more and more people are
saying that also causes death it causes
drug addiction it causes suicides it's a
lot of death caused by that there's no
win here just so we all understand there
is no win this is not a situation where
there's a win but the job that this
country has done the people of this
country it's incredible what they've how
they've endured how they've suffered
that's why we are in terms of deaths
it's so tremendous number one is too
many
right I've say it all the time but in
terms of death Brett we're at the lower
level the lowest level predicted and we
might not even hit
or maybe lower than that and sadly
that's all we can do and we're gonna do
a lightning round of questions some
short answers and some short questions
as well
but I want to start with you president
Trump were six months away from the
election today a different world than
when we were all together what
what kind of GDP what kind of employment
number do you think you're gonna need to
get the support of the American people
in November our country was sailing I
would tell people I would say you know
can this continue we were doing the
greatest ever greatest economy in
history of any country blowing away
everybody including China and then we
had it closed it and my ambition is very
quickly to get us back to where we were
and I think we can do that very very
quickly not of a Democrat comes in and
raises taxes they want to raise
everybody's taxes we're doing the
opposite and the payroll tax cut is very
important for getting people back to
work
what I want to do is number one we're
getting rid of the virus we have to do
it we're working with the governors
we're getting rid of the virus but we
got to put our country back to work all
those people out there that are
protesting they're right they want to go
back to work we want to go back to work
quickly but safely and that's what's
happening and then next year I think
we're gonna have a great economic year
we're gonna get our jobs back and I'll
go a step further we have a transition
third quarter we're gonna have a very
good fourth quarter we're gonna have a
great next year so we're six months to
the day when is the next Trump rally and
will you where AM L I don't know I mean
everybody wants the rallies the rallies
we've never had an empty seat from the
time I came down the escalator with a
person that became our great first lady
who people really loved and they loved
her at those rallies too and she's she
loves the people of this country we have
to they they're longing for the rallies
I get it all the time ask her nobody
can't have a rally I don't think we can
have a rally with an empty stadium with
nobody in there in other words you know
you may be able to pull it off a
baseball or football or a boxing or
basketball you can't pull off a rally
with a hundred person it wouldn't work
out too well so hopefully we'll be able
to do rallies and
last couple of months I mean I would
hope that within maybe the last couple
of months we'll be able to do rallies in
various mr. vice-president you went to
the Mayo Clinic you didn't wear a mask
your critics jumped on you for that then
you went to GM you did wear a mask was
that a concession to the critics or
you're sending mixed signals there well
from early on the CDC's made it clear
that you wear a mask to prevent you from
conveying the corona virus to other
people and since the President and I are
in the unique positions we're in were
tested often we're tested as well that's
why we're here without a mask as well I
didn't think it was necessary but I
should have worn the mask at the Mayo
Clinic and I wore it when I visited the
ventilator plant in Indiana and I think
it's it's it really is a statement about
the American people the way people have
been willing to step forward practice
social distancing wear masks and
settings where they can't do that and I
just have to tell you that I couldn't be
more grateful to see the way the
American people respond at first the
president called for 15 days to slow the
spread than 30 days to slow the spread
and and this was a great hardship on
families and on businesses large and
small but the American people did it
it's made an immense difference I
believe it saved thousands of lives and
as we go forward as we continue to
practice those principles all of us
together I know we'll get through this
so you were asked to speak at the West
Point graduation there's been some
pushback on that Tammy Duckworth a
veteran said it would be a good demo are
you going to do it and do you think that
it's worth the risk for those families
no risk are you ready
they wanted me to speak I didn't want to
speak I you know I love West Point I
grew up near my school and you know
where I went to high school was right
near West boy in New York military
academy so it was a mini West Point very
many but West Point says incredible
thing incredible place I love it I know
it well because you know I spent a lot
of time in West Point they wanted me to
come and speak then they changed a date
I believe it's June 13th and it's my
honor to speak but I didn't want to
necessarily do it what
doing is they're coming back a little
bit early they're going to be fully
tested is they're going to be very very
spread apart I said I want their
families to be there you know Mike made
the commencement address I did it last
year at the Air Force Academy Mike did
it this year there were no parents in a
big stadium and they were very spread
apart and it was fine but they asked me
to do it and I agree the generals asked
me what I please do it you know I'm the
President of the United States they
wanted it I'd love to have this for one
it is the president last thing what do
you tell your kids and grandkids about
Kovac 19 about this time what do you
tell him I sat down with my son I sat
down with my grandchildren I said a
terrible thing that's happened it's a
thing that we've never experienced I
said I guess you could go back over a
hundred years and you could go to 1917
and we experienced it but Europe
experienced it much worse it could have
been a hundred million people died but I
said something's happened but we're
going to be strong and we're going to
get out of it and our country is going
to be bigger and better and stronger
than ever before
president Trump vice president pants
secretary minuchin thank you very much
for your time honored and thank you